Again since we have the logarithm of one amount on one side, and the logarithm
with base 3 of another amount on the other side. We can set these amounts equal
to one another. Now this property only holds true if the bases are the same,
and we have one log on the left, and one log on the right. This means we have
three x minus 2 equal to x minus 4. Solving for x, I'll subtract x from both
sides to get 2 x minus 2 equals negative 4. We'll add 2 to both sides in order
to isolate the 2x. And finally, we'll divide both sides by positive 2 to get x
is equal to negative 1. But here's where we want to be careful. If we plug in a
negative 1 in for x, we'll have log base 3 of negative 5. The same would be
true on the right-hand side. If I plug in a negative 1 here, I'll have log base
3 of negative 5. But here's the question. Can we really take the log base 3 of
negative 5? What would that equal? Well, we'd be saying 3 raised to some
unknown power, equals negative 5. There's no power that we could raise the base
3 to that would make it equal to negative 5. So this we can't do. Remember that
we can't take the log of negative numbers, this number must be greater than
zero. This means x equals negative 1 isn't a solution so we have no solution.